mesdames et messieurs les vainqueurs des
soixante quatorzième hunger games
katniss everdeen épitomé là
elle n'est pas celle qui croit elle veut
juste sauver sa peau c'est aussi simple
que ça
mais elle est devenue leurs lueurs
d'espoir alors elles vont être éliminés
à votre avis elle doit mourir j'en
conviens mais de la bonne manière et au
bon moment katniss everdeen est un
symbole nul besoin de la détruire il
suffit de détruire son image
par leur montrant qu'elle est des nôtres
il faut les en convaincre
hilarion tellement qu'il la tuerait pour
vous
et métissée vous plaît aidez-moi
survivre à cette tournée cela ne
s'arrêtera pas avec votre retour à la
maison
alors on fait quoi à partir de
maintenant votre mission c'est de
divertir le peuple afin de lui faire
oublier qu'elles sont les vrais
problèmes et grand sourire moi ces
carnets ce mardi la fille du fonds
les gens tu observes katniss tulard
offert une chance à eux d'être assez
courageux pour la saisir
la vie tu m'as offert une chance oui de
vivre non de faire quelque chose
construits avant qu'ils les tuent car et
virtuels
elle est bien
son espèce tout entière doit être
erratiques et son espèce monsieur les
autres vainqueurs à kusel qu'ils sont
une menace à cause d'elle il se croit
invincible